now while there are a lot of locations
to get the vaccine demand is also
growing for testing
as cases rise in southern nevada many of
you reached out to us on where to go to
get tested
as a lot of appointments are booked
every day joe muller joining us now live
from unlv where there's now a
drive-through testing
and vaccine drive-through clinic
available and this one's interesting
because it's at night so let's check in
with joe
yes this is the second day this is
happening our second evening i should
say it starts in about 30 minutes but i
want to give you a live look here at
this hour take a look at the line of
folks just
here to get tested or to get their
vaccine yesterday this location was
nonstop i'm told about three quarters of
the people coming here
we're getting tested people i spoke to
today say the more sites we can get open
like this
the better took me about four days to
get
something scheduled as the cases go up
so does the need for testing i'm flying
on saturday and then they told me today
that
they're still not sure if i'll have my
results by them because they've been a
little busy
a number of testing sites and clinics
are open but not as many as we had a few
months ago
when it comes to the testing and so
forth i think they should have
more more testing sites at csn thursday
people said they were able to get in for
testing but some
not as quick as they would like i think
the delta variant really makes the
urgency of testing even
more important because it's much more
contagious dr jonathan victori from e-7
health says the demand for rapid tests
has prompted its clinics to get new
tests
we rolled out about 2-3 months ago at
e-7 health
12 to 24-hour testing and monday we're
rolling out
we're actually going to roll out
two-hour pcr testing
some are skipping rapid tests due to the
costs others say more testing times
could make a difference there does need
to be more availability and i think
there
needs to be easier access for everybody
back out here live this location here at
unlv stand fulton building is first come
first serve it opens at 5
30 and closes at 10 30. now we'll be
closed friday and saturday but it will
reopen
on sunday through next thursday so if
you want more information on this site
and other
testing and vaccine locations around
clark county you can head to our website
that is 8 news now.com
reporting live at unlv joe mullen 8 news
now